stop outsourcing your social media so
it's recently talked with Joanna Ella's
nikka who's the publishing editor at
small business resources com and she
asked me to write an article about how
entrepreneurs are outsourcing your
social media and I thought it'd be way
better to do a video because I can get
the passion out and really deliver it
for you guys so here we go this is for
you now I'm a big fan of social media
it's a primary driver for my business
growth right now and I was named by
forbes magazine as one of the top 40
social media marketing masters are you
social media in three main ways number
one is to connect with and build a
following number two is to sell products
and services and number three is to
create a platform I can use to show
Authority and you know why I do well on
social it's because of heart it's
because of caring is because of actually
standing for something that's not
something you can outsource i'm tired of
entrepreneurs coming up to me and saying
oh yeah yeah i hired a guy to do my
twitter stuff meanwhile they have no
idea what that person is posting and
they're getting zero results from it it
also happens with big companies who hire
agencies who then post content that is
just smashing stuff down your throat
instead of actually engaging with the
audience it's not like the people you
outsource to our bad people they're just
not you if you're invited by Oprah
Winfrey to go speak on her show would
you send an outsourced worker of course
not and social is bigger than Oprah this
isn't going away guys it's only becoming
more important if you look at the
fastest growing companies in the world
you look at what's making them
successful you look at how their
marketing themselves online marketing is
the number one driver of their growth
right now there's a reason why Facebook
and Google are worth hundreds of
billions of dollars if you don't catch
up you're gonna get left behind I
believe that every entrepreneur should
be on social every CEO should have
personal accounts and understand how it
works CEOs who are personally active on
social will start to win over CEOs who
aren't now you don't need to be the one
personally posting to your company's
channel and respond to the questions
that are coming in there but you
we need to make sure that the person
that you hire to do that lives breathe
sleeps your business loves when you
stand for and can embody that and take
that to social media stop outsourcing
your social media and take it seriously
you need to have in-house capabilities
it's going to be the number one driver
in your industry and if you don't open
your eyes and start making it a priority
you're going to be choking on your
competitors dust believe I'm counting oh
yeah I'm a singer songwriter and radio
personality I subscribe to Eva's
newsletter a few years ago it has really
helped me the newsletter is very
informative and inspiring and it has
helped me throughout my career so I
encourage you to don't give up you can
make it subscribe to Evans newsletter
today you won't regret it
you